Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That
number is 2192. David P Here is a comment
about my coverage of George Anthony devoted
there. Santos and specifically how I have sort
of taken a light touch when it comes to his
previous marriage to a woman. In particular,
I've said there's a long history of gay men who
are living as gay men publicly marrying women.
Also, the marriage to that particular woman
might have been an immigration scam. But anyway,
this caller says there's something else I'm doing
wrong in my commentary. Take a listen to this.
Speaker 3: So, David, I just have one little
complaint about your coverage of Jorge Santos.
Please. Are you talking about LGBT members
and gay gay men who are potentially married
to women of sexuality? But you've completely
forgotten the fact that bisexuals exist and
are attracted to both. I would appreciate
if in the future you keep that in mind and
don't you race to be in the LGBT community.
Speaker 1: I am not erasing bisexuality in
my coverage of George Anthony, David or Santos. He
has never asserted that he is bisexual. If that it
I would just be crow barring that in for we have
no reason to even consider that in the sense that
Santos has had every opportunity to talk about
his sexuality and he's never asserted that. So
it's not about he's either. I mean, I guess if
you could take the approach that if he's lying
about his sexual orientation, the truth could
be anything and that could include bisexual.
But I don't know why we would suspect that
in particular, other than the story of the
immigration scam, which quite frankly seems like
the most plausible one to me at this time. So I
would never a race bisexuality. But I also don't
know why I would necessarily insert it either.
We have a fantastic bonus show for you today.
We are going to talk about Senator Rick Scott
dropping his plan to cut Social Security and
Medicare despite the fact that he spent the
last two weeks claiming that that plan didn't
exist. But now he's dropping it. But it also
didn't exist. Very complicated. We also are going
to talk about one of the greatest culinary lies in
the history of the United States, the boneless
chicken wing. The boneless chicken wing. It
doesn't exist. There is no such thing. There's
no wing in a boneless wing. We're talking about
a piece of the chicken breast or the tenderloin.
And we are finally going to get to the bottom of
this culinary lie. And also, Ron DeSantis is now
looking to expand the death penalty in Florida.
What does this mean? How is the Catholic Church
reacting to it? A really interesting story about
Ron DeSantis that's not getting nearly the
attention it deserves. So we will talk about
all of those stories and more when I'm joined
on the bonus show by producer Pat. Oh, the.
Speaker 4: Bonus show where you want to
make money. Yeah. Everybody else who makes
money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: Let's make that cash.
Right. Alex on the bonus show, sign
up at join Pacman dot com. You can
use the coupon code 24 starts now to get
yourself a discount. I will see you that.